- [Narrator] As the world grows
in population and prosperity
we're going to need a
lot more of this stuff.
(doorbell) (static)
At the same time, we need to
dramatically reduce emissions.
If only we could stop
emitting so much carbon,
and put it to use somewhere.
- Like in this brick?
(static)
- If we're gonna
dramatically lower emissions,
we've gotta have a concrete plan.
(tape failing)
Get it, concrete plan?
Ah, nevermind.
(energetic music)
- [Male] This Great Big Story is by BP.
Fewer emissions, more energy.
This is the global energy challenge.
- [Narrator] Concrete,
it's built everything
from Hadrian's Wall,
to the very foundations
that support this lady,
and her whole city.
But its production and use also emits
up to 8% of the world's total emissions.
8%, that's a big deal.
(static)
The human love affair with concrete
can be traced back as far as 6500 B.C.
But it was the Romans
who really ran with it,
creating their world building
cement out of volcano ash,
and made stuff like this,
this, and this.
And here's that Hadrian again.
This time, with the Pantheon.
Show off.
(ping)
But as Rome fell, the recipe
for this empire building,
continent conquering group
was lost to the ages,
only to be reinvented 180
years ago by this guy,
and his handlebar mustache.
(static)
- You know, it's a market
that's a few thousand years old
that really has been making
concrete the same way
for a couple of hundred years.
- EP Henry is a privately held,
family company, fourth generation.
The company was known for innovation
regarding architectural block design
for schools, and hospitals,
and universities,
which we're still doing today.
(blast)
- Every time that
traditional Portland
cement is manufactured you
make a ton of CO2.
(static)
Concrete is already the second most
used material on the planet, after water.
With urbanization and growing population
more of it's going to
get used, not less of it.
- [Narrator] So what exactly
is the concrete making process?
- [Tom] If you look at
bread and concrete they
have a lot in common.
Basically anywhere in the
world uses essentially
the same raw materials.
- [Male] You have flour,
eggs and sugar and,
you have milk.
- [Tom] When you make concrete,
you've got rocks, you've
got sand, you've got water.
- But with Solidia you use the CO2.
- Can I talk about my brick now?
- [Narrator] Go ahead Vahit.
- I invented the cement that
can reduce the carbon
footprint of concrete by 70%.
The idea came to me...
here.
- [Narrator] Where all the
greatest innovations begin,
right?
- [Both] Cheers!
- [Male] Vahit's innovation
was figuring out how to
mimic mother nature and
make it in a synthetic way
that allowed us to have
much greater impact.
- [Vahit] I can take that CO2,
put it in my concrete,
and it's no longer CO2.
It's all gone.
- [Narrator] So Solidia Concrete
is made using CO2 instead of water?
Let's take a closer look.
- [Vahit] CO2 Molecule is quite stable but
when it goes into water,
the molecular structure
starts getting distorted.
(static)
- Then it makes it reactive,
and then it sees a
calcium ion in the water,
in the solution.
- Your PH is high enough,
so it will produce calcium carbonate and
you will keep consuming the CO2.
- [Narrator] Okay, give us
the simple version, Tom.
(static)
- We effectively take it, rip it apart,
put it back together as something that's
not ever coming out again.
(static)
- Today we're able to
run Solidia on this line,
right here.
- When we produce 1000
square feet of pavers
with Solidia Cement,
that's the equivalent of
someone planting 420 trees,
that's how impactful it is.
It is a better cement for a better planet.
(static)
- [Narrator] The CO2 used
in Solidia bricks comes from
places like whiskey distilleries,
and breweries,
which would otherwise be
released into the air.
Just imagine if the CO2
came from other industries.
- BP has been an important part of
our board from the beginning.
Not only in helping us get the
start up moving as a company,
but also helping us think
about the carbon mark,
and helping us think about
the different sources of CO2.
- Concrete is the second
largest consumed material on
earth after water.
We are talking about 4 billion
tons of cement worldwide.
Annual production.
So what we are doing here in Solidia,
I think it will be an
important component of
the climate challenge.
- [Narrator] This carbon eating concrete
really could make a big impact.
Well done team!
Here's to helping build a better future.
(upbeat music)